which can provide information on when it's safe to eat.
And our analyses indicate that fish simply copying other fish in their social network
could account for over 60 percent of the algae eaten by the fish community,
and thus could be critical to the flow of energy and resources
through coral reef ecosystems.
But these findings also suggest that overfishing,
a common problem in coral reefs,
not only removes fish,
but it could break up the social network of remaining fish,
which may hide more and eat less algae
because they're missing critical information.
And this would make coral reefs more vulnerable than we currently predict.
So remarkably, fish social networks
allow the actions of one to spread to many
and could affect entire coral reefs,
which feed millions of us
and support the global economy
for all of us.
Now, our discovery points us towards better ways
to sustainably manage coral reefs,
but it also shows us,
we humans are not just affected by the actions of other humans,
but we could be affected by the actions of individual fish
on a distant coral reef
through their simple copying behavior.
Thank you.
(Applause)